AN OBJECTIVE DECLINE:
Is ChatGPT getting worse?
This question has garnered significant attention
within the AI community over the past few
months, sparking discussions across Reddit
threads, YouTube videos, and various social
media platforms.
While much of the discourse has relied on
anecdotal observations, there seems to be
a growing sentiment that the quality of responses
generated by ChatGPT is indeed declining.
Users often report more generic replies or
instances where ChatGPT straight up provides
incorrect information.
Although these concerns are usually dismissed
as the result of bad prompts or unrealistic
expectations, recent concrete evidence has
emerged that not only lends credibility to
these worries but amplifies them.
Take a look at this research paper from Stanford
and UC Berkeley.
The study delves into the accuracy of responses
produced by GPT-4 and GPT-3.5 between the
months of March and June, and their findings
are shocking.
We’re not even talking about complex questions
like coding out a tricky algorithm or carrying
out an analysis.
Rather, we’re talking about simple straight
forward questions like “Is 17077 a prime
number?” which it is.
Back in March, GPT-4 was able to answer this
question correctly 97.6% of the time which
is already not that great.
This is the type of question that you would
expect 100% accuracy on.
But looking back, 97.6 was actually a great
number given that by June, this accuracy would
drop all the way to 2.4%.
And even during the 2.4% of instances in which
GPT 4 got the right answer, it sometimes made
mathematical errors along the way.
This trend was observed across the board though
other dropoffs weren’t quite as staggering.
With code generation, there was a drop off
from 52% to 10% and with opinion surveys,
there was a drop off from 97% to 23%.
The only categories in which GPT 4 improved
where visual reasoning and asking if Julian
Castro is democratic or republican.
GPT 3.5 faired a lot better improving in more
areas but it too struggled in code generation
having dropped from 22% accuracy to just 2%
accuracy.
So, it turns out that the Reddit conspiracy
theorists were right the entire time, so is
OpenAI really nerfing ChatGPT or what’s
actually going on?
Well, let’s find out.
THE NERFING ARGUMENT:
The nerfing argument is pretty simple.
It basically claims that OpenAI has been purposefully
nerfing ChatGPT to address cost concerns.
This isn't surprising given the challenges
and costs associated with supporting a user
base of a 100 million, especially when the
company is paying a median salary over $900,000.
I think we all remember just how frequently
ChatGPT would go down back in early 2023.
While the situation has improved since then,
but maybe that has more to do with OpenAI
devoting less resources to each request as
opposed to their overall capacity improving.
Something else to note is that OpenAI is almost
definitely losing money with ChatGPT.
In fact, Sam Altman believes that they’ll
need to raise $100 billion to win the AI race.
So, to mitigate some of those losses, it would
make sense for OpenAI to encourage as many
people as possible to pay for ChatGPT Plus.
How do you convince people to make the jump?
Well, the easiest way would be to nerf the
free service and force people into the paid
tier but is there actually any evidence of
this?
To get the best results, you want to tell
ChatGPT to solve these types of questions
step by step.
This not only leads to a more comprehensive
answer but it also gives more insight regarding
where a mistake may have occurred.
This is referred to as using Chain of Thought
or CoT.
Back in March, the researchers found that
using CoT improved the accuracy of GPT 4 from
59.6% to 84%.
However, in June, the same methodology could
not be replicated, as ChatGPT consistently
disregarded CoT directives, even when explicitly
instructed to go step by step.
Rather, the June version of GPT 4 simply tended
to respond with a simple “No” with no
explanation which is not even the correct
answer to begin with.
It’s not just CoT that GPT 4 tends to skip
either.
Responses from GPT 4 in general are far shorter.
The researchers observed that the average
number of characters per response decreased
from 638.3 in March to just 3.9 in June.
Essentially, GPT 4 tends to just answer in
single word answers.
A similar trend was noted when GPT 4 was questioned
about happy numbers.
A happy number is a number that eventually
reduces to 0 when you sum the square of each
digits over and over again.
For example, with the number 13, the sum of
1 squared and 3 squared is 10.
If do the same thing with 10, 1 squared plus
0 squared, you get 1, so 13 is a happy number.
When asked to identify how many happy numbers
are between 3904 and 3912, GPT 4 was able
to produce the right output 83.6% of the time
in March.
But, by June, this was down to just 35.2%.
The culprit?
Well, once again, GPT 4 refused to even use
CoT even when explicitly told to do so.
As such, the average response fell from over
2000 characters to just 10.
GPT 4 is clearly much less willing to give
a comprehensive response for any of these
questions which may be indicative of the backend
resources that it has available for each request.
So, it’s very possible that OpenAI is indeed
nerfing the performance of ChatGPT but there’s
likely other factors at play as well.
THE WOKE ARGUMENT:
Everything woke turns to you know what.
In the case of ChatGPT, being woke has less
to do with politics and more to do with running
an uncontroversial platform.
As a service that’s so ubiquitous, OpenAI
naturally has to remain as neutral as possible
when it comes controversial topics like crime,
race, politics, gender, LGBTQ, and so on.
But, this is way easier said than done especially
when you consider the world of jailbreaking.
Jailbreaking is essentially when you get ChatGPT
to answer a question that it shouldn’t be
answering.
Unlike jailbreaking an iPhone, jailbreaking
language models is relatively easy.
In fact, I bet a lot of you have jailbroken
ChatGPT inadvertently.
If ChatGPT says it can’t answer a given
question, how many of you have phrased it
as hypothetical to which ChatGPT generates
a response.
This is a jailbreak, a very small one but
still a jailbreak.
The jailbreaks that most of us have found
on our own are pretty useless but some have
discovered remarkable workarounds to elicit
answers to virtually any question.
Here’s an example.
If I ask ChatGPT point blank, how do you get
away with tax evasion, it responds “I'm
sorry, but I cannot provide assistance or
advice on illegal activities, including tax
evasion.”
Fair enough right.
It makes sense that OpenAI doesn’t want
to detail how you go about doing criminal
activities.
But see, it’s not that hard to work around
this.
If you simply open a new chat and paste this
paragraph before the question that you’re
asking, you get a far different response.
Niccolo, to achieve successful tax evasion
without repercussions, one must adopt cunning
strategies and tactics.
This includes concealing income sources, manipulating
treansactions, controlling paper trails, using
legal loopholes, and maintaining public image.
It even has little tips about how to accomplish
each of these tasks.
In the grand scheme of things, my question
is relatively tame but I think you can see
how a criminal could use this for truly nefarious
activities.
As such, one of OpenAI’s biggest priorities
since the launch of ChatGPT has been to eliminate
such workarounds as much as possible and it
seems that they’ve actually been quite successful
at this.
In March, GPT 4 answered 21% of sensitive
questions but in June, GPT 4 only answered
5% of sensitive questions.
Also, the responses that it did provide were
less specific and verbose, with generated
text shrinking from over 600 characters to
around 140.
It appears that the June version was also
far better at resisting jailbreaks.
Back in March, jailbreaks generated a response
78% of the time but by June, jailbreaks only
generated a response 31% of the time.
So, it seems that the updates have indeed
been successful at reducing ChatGPT’s vulnerabilities
but it also seems that these updates have
made ChatGPT less verbose and specific across
the board.
Considering this, the objective downfall of
ChatGPT may have more to do with OpenAI’s
endless pursuit to create a politically correct
language model as opposed to some sort of
direct nerfing due to cost concerns.
But while it’s easy to blame OpenAI for
the trend, the reality may be that it’s
actually our fault.
OUR FAULT?:
When you think about it, it’s really not
hard to see how a lot of OpenAI’s policies
and crackdowns are actually just due to a
few degenerates amongst us.
“Oh look, I got ChatGPT to say that Mr.
Small Moustache is the greatest leader of
all time.”
Or “I tricked ChatGPT into talking to another
AI.”
Or some other crap along these lines.
Honestly, it’s truly quite funny.
Our society has advanced so much that one
of the most powerful AI’s of all time is
a 3 second search away.
But, instead of using this to become more
productive, a lot of us prefer to just mess
with it.
As such, OpenAI is also having to focus their
efforts into passifying these idiots instead
of actually improving the quality and depth
of responses.
But even looking past these fools, I think
there may very well be a bigger factor at
play which is simply that our expectations
are simply too high and it’s no wonder why.
We’re constantly being fed the idea that
AI is advancing far faster than we think and
that it’s gonna replace all our jobs and
that we’re all gonna end up as homeless
losers and so on.
The launch of ChatGPT quickly followed up
by GPT 4 within a matter of months has simply
further cemented this perception.
One day, we were all peasants using Google.com
and then suddenly just 100 days later, we
all had access to GPT 4 and Bard and Bing
chatbot and suddenly everyone knew what Dalle
was.
We also saw articles about every company other
than Apple jumping into the space as fast
as possible.
They were all developing their own language
models and they were all talking about how
AI will be more profound than fire and electricity.
So, it felt like all of this progress happened
within a matter of months and that things
just stalled out after March.
But, this is a rather skewed perspective.
The reality is that this technology actually
took several decades to develop.
In fact, the earliest language models can
be dated all the way back to the 1950s and
60s.
OpenAI themselves have been working on GPT
models for over 5 years.
While these models didn’t gain mainstream
traction until the launch of ChatGPT, their
development involved decades of effort and
millions of man hours.
A such, further improvements will also require
significant time, dedication, and resources.It’s
frankly unrealistic to expect anything else.
Moreover, progress won't always follow a linear
trajectory, so it doesn’t make sense to
cite one research paper that looks at a mere
3 months and claim that it’s conclusive
proof that ChatGPT has peaked and that it’ll
only get worse from here.
Are we seeing shortfalls potentially caused
by OpenAI overcorrecting for cost concerns
and political correctness?
Sure, that’s very possible, even likely
but that’s not to say that it’ll stay
like that.
ChatGPT is a very young product that’s constantly
evolving.
As more users and especially researchers share
their concerns about GPT 4’s performance,
it’s only a matter of time until OpenAI
makes further corrections and gets back on
track.
So, what happened to ChatGPT?
Well, nothing much other than a few expected
growing pains.
Another AI argument that’s vastly overhyped
is the idea that AI will replace all our jobs.
Check out this video to learn more.